I spent my holiday catching up on old movies.
One of them was "Back to the Future",...
...and while I was watching that movie,...
...I thought with today's advanced technology,...
...a time machine no longer sounds impossible.
What are your thoughts on that?
Do you think the era of time machines will come true?
If so, do you hope to alter the events of the past?
I do enjoy reading and watching movies or books that are about futurism.
And I believe that it's simply a matter of time before we invent the time machine.
I mean, look at all these unbelievable technological means today!
If I had a chance to go back in time,...
...I would choose to go back ten years from today,...
...to fix any regrettable moments that I have had throughout my entire lifetime.
Well, I also thought about going back to times when I made major, big mistakes.
But I believe that we all learn from mistakes,...
...so maybe it'd be better to just leave things the way they are.
Speaking of time machines, I think they would bring chaos to society,...
...and all human beings would want to be perfect, rich and smart.
On the other hand, it would be good if we could change something such as the events that have caused the outbreak of wars.
What a brilliant idea!
I've never thought about it before.
I really wish we could go back to the time before the war and stop it,...
...so that many people don't have to die.
If it was possible, I'm sure this world would be much more peaceful than it is now.
I can't wait to see a working time machine!